if the welcome so good to see you here
at home them and in a couple of months
we'll meet again but then a special one
of the speakers for our conference what
will save the world and would you please
be so kind to introduce yourself to the
Dutch audience your cosmopolitan you're
a novelist maybe you can tell a little
bit about yourself yeah all right I'm a
writer novelist I'm a storyteller that's
how I connect with the world through
stories and through imagination that
said I also have an academic background
and interdisciplinary background I was
educated in international relations then
I have done master's degree in women's
studies and then for PhD political
science or political philosophy and I
have always kept my connection with
academia throughout the years movie
I'm also public speaker and commentator
on various issues that I think I
important in the world today so I do
write for various publications around
the world to me all of that is there all
in harmony but at the same time maybe
there's a gap because by nature I'm
introvert as a writer
my job is based on solitude but I also
have this other science that likes to
engage in public debates and likes to
think about the issues that matter today
now is one of the gifts of being a
writer and the power of imagination are
you like a huge power favorite native
everybody knows who have read your books
that when you look at nowadays world as
a writer now what is it that you see
well I see lots of science that I find
quite alarming
maybe I'm aggression in that regard I
always share this pessimism of the
intellect and the optimism of the world
optimism of the heart so I'm half
business to carve up the mistake
I am half pessimistic because when I
look at the science today I see a very
strong trend back to what I call
tribalism activation state nationalism
religiosity all those devices are forces
that many intellectuals in nineteen
forties fifties thought were going to
disappear gradually that did not happen
in fact the opposite happens they made a
very strong comeback so religion is a
major factor today nationalism indeed so
but also this tribalism you know
dividing humanity on based on the basis
of imaginary categories
I am half optimistic when I've got the
people global source I'm a big believer
in cosmopolitanism I'm a big believer in
the truth that in this world if we're
ever going to learn anything we will
learn it from people who are different
from us I have nothing to learn from
someone who's exactly like me who thinks
exactly like me
but someone is different or challenge me
perhaps I'll challenge into so that
diversity that cosmopolitanism that we
are belittling today it's something that
we really need to renew and also I
believe in the power of humanism empathy
in the rule of empathy on which very
much the art of storytelling his days
well then the question is and we will
discuss of course lengthy at the
conference but the big question is what
happened after World War two we built
our international institutions like the
United Nations and we have wonderful
NGOs like Human Rights Watch Amnesty
International we became more prosperous
Raziel
development in technology science and
then the fall of the Berlin Wall
lost a huge sense of optimism in the
early 90s
so how come do you think that that we
have now this backward tendency yeah
there was indeed a huge wave tide of
optimism in the sense that many
Smart's intellectuals they thought that
thanks to globalization they were all
going to become a big global village and
everybody would have primarily economic
and social ties and that would help to
transcend national and nationalistic
boundaries it did not happen in that way
I think we need to bear in mind that
when we think about time we tend to
think that time always goes in a linear
direction but we have seen that time
does not always go forward it sometimes
draw circles it can move backwards
in other words what I'm trying to say is
if we learn nothing from the mistakes of
the past we are bound to make those
mistakes again and again and again and
that is what is so sad how memory is
lost and I'm not talking about like a
very long term memory of centuries I'm
talking about recent political memory
even with regards to Europe the EU how
it was established how the journey began
very few people today are talking about
the beginning that spirits that
initiated everything so we tend to think
take things granted very easily and I
find myself in this a bit ironic use
situation to tell you the truth because
coming from Turkey a country that's on
the fringes of Europe I found myself I
live in
in the UK I find myself defending more
passionately what I regard as European
values for me the EU is not primarily a
financial project or other quality
project it's primarily about values
which mean a lot to me and by those
values I mean freedom of speech
primarily separation of powers rule of
law
definitely women's rights LGBT rights
minority rights and many other human
rights that all together make sense so I
do not take these values for granted
because I do know that societies can
lose them
neither do I take cosmopolitanism for
granted because I come from a country
that has lost its cosmopolitan heritage
and I think by losing that Turkey loss
tonight